watch what happens when I play some
small drops of food coloring onto this
slide some are attracted to each other
and merge while others repel and chase
each other it looks just like the tiny
world of microorganisms but why well if
you want to try this out for yourself
you need to get some ordinary food
coloring and dilute it with distilled
water using a pipette then pass the
microscope slide through a flame for
about 30 seconds let it cool and then
put some drops of different
concentration onto the slide you'll find
that drops of similar concentration
attract each other and merge while drops
of different concentrations chase each
other
you can draw guides on the slide using
permanent marker which is hydrophobic
and set up long distance pursuits or you
can find the drops of similar
concentration attract each other despite
the hydrophobic barriers but how is this
possible just using ordinary food
coloring and water well the key is
evaporation each drop is constantly
evaporating so around it is an envelope
of vapor the rate of evaporation depends
on the humidity around the drop so the
drier the air is the faster the rate of
evaporation so when any two drops are
close enough the humidity between them
is greater than the humidity around them
and therefore there's more evaporation
around the droplets than in-between them
and this pushes them together so
differential evaporation makes the
droplets attract but that's not the
whole story
food coloring is a mixture of mainly two
molecules water and propylene glycol
these two liquids mix well so we say
they are miscible but they have
different properties for example water
evaporates more readily because it's
lighter and it has a stronger surface
tension due to hydrogen bonding and this
is important because interesting things
happen when there are gradients in
surface tension for example if I add
some pepper to this bowl of water to
allow me to see the motion and then I
add a little dab of soap right in the
middle you see that all of the water
rushes outwards and this is because soap
has a lower surface tension than water
you can think of it a bit like a
tug-of-war before I added the soap all
of those water molecules were pulling on
each other equally but once I add the
soap molecules in the middle they're
weaker surface tension means the water
molecules around them are pulling harder
on each other than the soap is and so
they rush outwards away from that
spreading soap drop and this motion is
called Marangoni flow and a similar
thing is actually happening with our
food coloring droplets if you have drops
of similar concentration they attract
each other due to the higher humidity in
between them and they merge and although
drops of different concentration also
attract each other they
merge when they come into contact this
is because the water in the lower
concentration drop pulls together and
away from the drop with the higher
concentration of propylene glycol just
like with the soap and water and
differential evaporation drives the two
drops forwards it is fascinating to
watch these droplets and think about how
closely their motion mimics life living
organisms seek out molecules like food
and this is a process known as
chemotaxis but what these droplets are
doing is really not all that dissimilar
in fact it's been called artificial
chemotaxis and as amazingly lifelike as
their motion appears in a way I think it
shouldn't be all that surprising after
all evolution began with the natural
tendencies of molecules to form and
break apart to attract and repel and
then over billions of years of
refinement through natural selection
evolution has produced bodies whose
utilization of these natural tendencies
of molecules appears miraculous and it's
that that we call life I tried using
slides that hadn't been passed through a
flame and then I couldn't get the drops
to move so I'm researching this further
I found out that passing the microscope
slide through the flame creates a high
energy surface and what that means is
the flame is essentially breaking open
some of the bonds the glass bonds in the
surface of this slide and when you put
the droplet on top it's those open bonds
is that high energy surface that draws
some of the water molecules away from
the droplet and then actually makes the
water molecule more likely to evaporate
but as just happened right there some of
the microscopes some of the microscope
slides have shattered and so you should
be particularly careful when doing this
procedure obviously heating them up to a
very high temperature causes them to
expand a lot and when they contract
again as they're cooling well then they
sometimes break apart because of those
stresses